today i am not in germany with bmw at
their next gen event for the launch of
the bmw ix as we had originally planned
so instead they sent the car to me
sort of this is the most unique way to
do a car launch i mean we're seeing it
here
before anybody else actually gets to see
it and then we're going to 3d print it
and see it in real life but in the palm
of my hands i went to ces with bmw this
year and i had the best time ever and we
talked about how much fun we were going
to have when i would come out to germany
this year
and unfortunately because pretty much
the whole world has
shut down and all of the travel
restrictions i wasn't able to make it
out but they still wanted me to feel
like i was a part of the launch
and to be able to bring you guys along
for the ride all puns intended
so since the car was being launched
today they wanted me to be able to
see the car feel the car touch the car
but obviously
they couldn't send the actual car here
but what they did send
was a 3d printer all of the accessories
the materials and a 3d file to print out
a
tiny replica so i could actually see the
thing for myself
they're calling this the tiny launch
like a tiny launch that's like the
cutest thing
i've ever heard so what's even more fun
is the fact that i got to watch
this thing be printed i've never printed
anything before in my entire life by
myself
in 3d so the fact that this was my first
print
an unreleased never before seen brand
new bmw ix this vehicle design
marks the beginning of an all-new era
for electric vehicles so my friends
let's take to the 3d printer
and print ourselves a card before we get
into this let me just tell you that 3d
printing takes a very long time
i think this total project probably took
over two days of just print time
[Music]
we have the model in place everything is
ready to go we're gonna do a time lapse
are you guys ready so right now it's
sending
the car to the printer this actual
printing process
took several days from the shell to the
rims to the outer tires
and this type of printing process that
we did was actually a very different
process than i've ever seen before
it uses liquid resin which is then
released inside of this tank
and very precise lasers will etch this
resin and harden it so it's basically
being built from the bottom up
the print is finished
26 hours later
and then you take it out and then you
put it in a very high concentrate of
alcohol you give it a little bath
this is so cool i wish that i was in
germany right now for the launch but i
guess
this is the next best thing i just love
that they're calling this
a tiny launch it's a tiny launch
i think 3d printing is easy i think it's
like an easy thing
you think it's just like you know you
push print and then you're done
spoiler alert you want a high quality
print that's not the case
so now i need to clean this up get it in
the curing oven
[Music]
oh you're wondering why it's dark uh
maybe because this process
has taken a very long time
[Music]
i think i did it so now i guess we wait
for this to dry
repeat the same process for the wheels i
love my new hobby
[Music]
i mean it's almost like being in germany
it's so so lifelike
can you imagine me this is me
okay so my wheel fell off i am so
just impressed the fact that i did not
mess up my first print and i'm very
grateful that i didn't because
we didn't have enough time to be able to
print another one and get this video up
for you guys
so a vehicle like this usually has a
lead time of several years but today
bmw is showcasing their first model and
it's pretty cool that we're actually
getting to take a look at this thing
before it's even out i am very sad
though that i'm not actually there in
person to get to see it to sit in it and
to just sort of
feel what it's like to actually be in
this car but i feel
so grateful that i'm still able to
participate in the fun by getting to
print one of these for you guys to see
while this very spacious cozy interior
might look like a place that you can
relax
this car can go from zero to a hundred
real quick in about five seconds it has
two electric motors that have maximum
output of more than 500 horsepower it
also has dc
fast charging so you can charge the
battery from 10 to 80
of its full capacity in 40 minutes a 10
minute fast charge will add 75 miles to
the car's range i love bmw's focus on
sustainability and this car is no
exception
the power used to produce the battery
cells the high voltage battery and the
entire vehicle itself
comes exclusively from renewable sources
there's a high proportion of recycled
and natural materials that were used for
the exterior and the interior
and the leather is tanned with olive
leaf extracts i talked a lot about the
sustainability that bmw
has been doing in my video that i did at
ces so it's really cool to see them sort
of follow through with all of that in
this one as well
the new intelligence panel has
integrated sensors a camera and radar
technology for advanced driver
assistance this is bringing together the
latest innovation in the fields of
electric mobility
automated driving and intelligent
connectivity 5g my friends
the future of 5g is just gonna give us
so many more opportunities
and this is 5g enabled so it'll allow
for optimized automated driving
and parking functions now the doors have
frameless windows the tailgate has no
separation joints
and this extends across the entire back
of the car these new design changes
are allowing for increased efficiency
and range with the intelligent
lightweight design and aerodynamics it's
made of an aluminum space frame
construction with carbon cage
now this curved interior display we just
needed i'm just gonna
did you see that let me just back that
video up for you because we need to see
it again
it's a fully digital screen made up of a
12.3 inch display and a 14.9 inch
control display and it's a single piece
of frameless glass
and i just cannot stop looking at this
image of it and i've just been replaying
this video clip
over and over i also really like these
seats these are also newly developed
with this new style of head restraint
there's extra leg room and there's space
for storage compartments
plus this center console kind of looks
like a high quality piece of furniture
and this little dial hold on let's
replay the clip
it's like a diamond doorknob something
that i think everyone needs
maybe not in their home but in their car
we also need to take a moment to check
out the steering wheel
it's hexagonal which kind of gives it
this really neat futuristic look
and this panoramic glass roof is also
very impressive
it has the electrochromic shading which
is available as an add-on option
and this is so cool because when you
press a button it'll basically turn it
into a tinted glass
without having to do anything it is
magical
i am so excited for the future of
electric vehicles and everything that
car manufacturers are doing to keep
improving on this technology and i've
been loving everything that bmw has been
showcasing and i'm even more excited to
hopefully get a chance
in the near future to give this a test
drive until then i will see you guys
here on the internet at bmw congrats on
another amazing launch and thank you so
much for including me in this
even though i couldn't join you guys in
germany hopefully one of these days soon
i will see you guys all again
in real life trying to get you out of
here bud
i hope i can get you out by the time
they launch this vehicle because at this
rate
i don't know